all right you guys have seen my top 10
favorite movies of 2014 now here's the
reverse the opposite side of it going
the top 10 worst movies of 2014 for my
opinion and what I mean by that is if
you liked or had fun with any of the
movies on this particular list that is
awesome as long as you're having fun at
the movies these are just the movies I
myself did not have fun with and I
probably should have I don't like long
introductions so I'm gonna get on with
the list of movies that I felt were so
bad I just have to talk about them one
more time in the year that's here number
10 starting off our list we have brick
mansions this is actually a remake of
another movie and I had heard praises
about the original movie and so I saw
this movie no okay that tells me one
thing either everybody is drunk on a
shitty original movie or oh this remake
missed the mark entirely and it's
nothing like the original I liked all
the cool parkour [ __ ] but it is a rarity
to see a movie sprinkled with such a
logic it's just that baffling somewhere
before the plot point where someone was
like hey we have five minutes to drive
that nuke away from the city I'll do it
I had already checked out that just
sealed it number nine
next we have Annabelle this is the
prequel to the conjuring springboarding
off of that movie successful like hey we
can just make a movie sage the prequel
to the conjuring and everyone will go
watch it it doesn't have to be good it
doesn't have to be entertaining in fact
he can be boring [ __ ] this movie was
indeed boring as [ __ ] I give the movie
props for that one scene in the basement
that was actually pretty creepy now if
they could have kept that going
throughout the entire movie or at least
half the movie I would have been
entertained but this movie dragged on
actually ended up screening this movie
with two other people in the theater and
at a point it was like Mystery Science
Theater we were just talking [ __ ] about
the movie that was actually fun the
guilty pleasure movies are fun doesn't
mean they're good though yeah I'm
talking about I Frankenstein but why is
this thing was Frankenstein he's all
like he looks like Aaron Eckhart so he's
all chiseled body like yes I am
Frankenstein but I talk gruff cuz I was
in The Dark Knight and taking cues from
him I get this movie good time if you're
drunk as I said in my review if you are
drunk this is the guilty pleasure moving
you'll probably have fun with it example
Street Fighter the van Damme movie is my
guilty pleasure movie however if someone
was making a list of the top ten worst
movies a 1994 street fighter had better
be on there because
is not good and neither is I
Frankenstein the Motor City next are you
sick of Melissa McCarthy I wasn't until
I saw Tammy now I kind of am I was
looking forward to tanning because it's
Melissa McCarthy and she's good in those
roles and she was still functional in
the role in this movie but this movie oh
my god what a mess it wasn't funny it
was awkward it was boring it was a drama
in all the wrong ways it's not a comedy
with dramatic moments and heart and
that's all good no it's an awkward drama
d with really awkward drama one thing I
cannot stand is an awkward mother-son
mother-daughter duo and this was that
this movie clearly tried to be sold on
Melissa McCarthy being Melissa McCarthy
now everyone's wise to that act so this
movie hell no number six guys there's no
real reason transcendent should have
been one of the biggest bores of the
year but it was some of you may not know
this there was a time Johnny Depp was a
great actor the guy has acting chops I
have seen it so you have an accomplished
actor in a movie about a guy who gets
uploaded into the internet like the
[ __ ] lawn mower man this should have
been awesome but it was not when this
movie came out on blu-ray I was hanging
out with someone who got it is what I'm
gonna watch it knows like don't do that
and then he put it in and I sat down and
watched it because I'm a team player
like that oh my god I forgot how boring
it actually was it tries to come across
as this pseudo intellectual like who
would is humanity who is human in the
reality of execution it moves along like
an old guy with a really bad prostate
problem you know you ever hear your
grandfather piss and it sounds like that
is the base of this movie number 5 yeah
there is string of shitty horror movies
this year Paranormal Activity the marked
ones that's another this was the moment
like when Paranormal Activity came out I
was like yeah that was cool that was
creepy and some people were like it was
boring as [ __ ] but I enjoyed it and even
the second one on the third one I
started doing less and less but I'm
still on board with the franchise at
this point this is two movies too many
the franchise has such an ego at this
point too like no this isn't actually
the official sequel to Paranormal
Activity this is a spin-off because we
can do that because we're that relevant
no you're not know what you are you are
not that great anymore
movie even tries to have the balls to
tie into the first one at the end and to
their credit no they just failed it
doesn't make sense the timings all off I
officially want this franchise to die
dumb flu or told you there were a few of
these shitty movies Devil's Due was
among them talk about generic as horror
movie granted we've pretty much seen
most of what we can see in the horror
movie genre at this point in life but
Devil's Due doesn't even make an attempt
it's like well let's just kind of do
everything that people have seen before
and we'll just pass it off as maybe
it'll be ironic it's fashionable it's
vintage will repackage it and resell it
as something new no no the plot holes
and loopholes in this movie will make
your head spin you're like that makes
zero sense a movie that has satanic cult
nonsense still needs to make sense by
the end of it number three you know what
sucks ass movies based off of board
games and shitty scary movies this one
it's both and it's Ouija what what is
this thing it was a funny thing about it
is when I'd watch the movie and did my
review I didn't eat it didn't dawn on me
that the movie was based off of the
board game Ouija you know like
battleship and all that [ __ ] I just
thought it was Luigi there was a Ouija
board that's why it's called Ouija I
didn't get that it was actually based
off of the board game don't worry it
would have made my list before I thought
that because this movie is [ __ ] to the
tenth degree the acting sucks the
premise is [ __ ] this movie has so many
holes in it by the end of the movie you
walk out you're like nope if that was no
I guess that's what pisses me off in
movies is when there are loopholes in
the movie and the plot actually
deconstructs itself while you're
watching it that's bad enough when
you're paying the actors $7 an hour
because you can that's just where I
don't know what they made but I swear to
God if it was more than seven dollars an
hour it was too much no hmm and you guys
knew this was going to be on here it's
not quite a horror movie kind of kind of
is but it's definitely based off of toys
yeah transformers age of extinction this
movie I went into this movie going okay
maybe Michael Bay can turn over a new
leaf you have new actors you have new
Autobots new Decepticons it's it's a new
premise at this point it's a new
Transformers franchise could've been and
then he just starts doing is Michael
Bay's am you're like nope you're
actually the guy that killed
transformers before if the movie ended
at a certain point I would have been
like the movies light as [ __ ] it's not
good but it can still be a guilty
pleasure movie but the movie goes on for
an extra 45
minna-san which are just being
waterboarded with this metal orgy of
Michael Bay [ __ ] Oh again if you had
fun with this movie I am glad you can do
that I can't I can't tell anybody to
watch this movie
no ball boy coming in at number one I
know some of you thought that
transformers age of extinction was gonna
be my number one nope early on in the
year there was another one that I saw
and I was like if this is gonna be on
the top 10 list for sure and it turns
out no movie this year was shittier to
me than this movie legend of Hercules oh
my god I don't know where to begin with
this movie holy [ __ ] the sets were
[ __ ] the costumes looked like a
shitty school play the acting was worse
than that I still laugh when I think
about the bad guy in this movie and is
overacting about ah me a break bad guys
can be menacing without being cartoons
this guy he was the worst part of
Saturday morning cartoons the fights
were even nonsense about that scene
where I do get stabbed and touched the
spear under his arm facing the camera or
this way yeah he could have faked it
you'd be like I think you're tucked
under his arm but yeah I don't know for
sure but when he gets like this and
talked city might as well just look at
the camera be like Nana Nana Nana Nana
Nana Nana Nana you can watch this movie
for laughs it doesn't change the fact
that it's actually the shittiest movie
in the year I haven't seen the Dwayne
the rock Johnson movie I should watch
this one then the Dwayne the rock
Johnson Hercules so I could be like oh
my god that's like gladiator
that's like legit Ridley Scott epic
right there yeah that movie still with
me I still remember the horror to this
day alright guys those are the top ten
shittiest movies is you're granted there
are some shitty movies I didn't watch
they didn't come into a theater near me
and I was like I don't feel like driving
thirty minutes to go watch that shitty
movie that everyone says a shitty yeah
to my everlasting shame or pride I
didn't go Sam but if the ones I saw
these are them all right I usually don't
like being a negative Nancy here but
your list of the top ten shittiest
movies of 2014
what is it what are they whatever they
are comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more